quelques minutes après l'impact des tirs
au pied de ligne à très haute tension
directement reliée à la centrale
nucléaire de zappos ridja
aucune image plus proche ne nous
parvient pour le moment les russes
occupent depuis des mois ce site
nucléaire est interdite d'accès la
centrale de zappos ridja se trouve à la
limite nord du territoire occupé par les
russes elle est actuellement co gérée
avec la compagnie nucléaire ukrainienne
qui affirme que le bombardement a
entraîné l'extinction automatique de
l'un des réacteurs ainsi que des dégâts
importants
il existe toujours des risques de fuites
d'hydrogène et de substances
radioactives et le risque d'incendié est
également élevé
ces photos ont été transmises par le
gouverneur pro russe de la région qui
confirme la rupture de deux lignes à
haute tension mais lui renvoient la
responsabilité aux combattants du
kremlin c'est la deuxième fois que la
centrale de zappos ridge a subi des tirs
d'artillerie en mars les russes
s'étaient ainsi emparé du site suscitant
l'indignation internationale
aujourd'hui le chef de la diplomatie
européenne condamne la russie pour je
cite une violation grave et
irresponsable des règles de sécurité
nucléaire